- This past Valentine's day
we had two awesome comedians
here who have fallen in love.
I'm talking about Chelsea
Handler and Joe Coy.
Remember this?
Look, I'm not a pop culture,
I never know what's happening.
And I was reading my script
last night and I was like, what?
I had no idea y'all were dating.
And I'm very, I don't know
why I'm excited about this.
It's kind of weird that I
would be excited about this
because I don't know y'all
that well, but I just love it.
Two comedians like dating.
Who's the funniest at home, come on.
- This one.
- Oh
- Okay. Okay.
- Well, no, we're both.
I mean, I'm bitchy funny,
you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Which is funny.
- He's funny, funny.
He's like sweet, funny, good natured funny
and then I come in and I'm like, you know.
- Yeah. She just knocks down all the pins.
- [Kelly] Go for the jugular.
- Yeah.
- Like here comes bowling
ball and it's Chelsea.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I just think this would be
the greatest show ever to watch.
So wait, so do you remember
the first time y'all met, Joe?
- Yeah. It was a long, long time.
Well, here's the thing I remember.
She doesn't remember.
- Well, first of all, shut up.
Okay. Second.
I remember.
What I do remember, Kelly,
is that this very studio
was where we we filmed Chelsea Lately
for like four or five years.
Yeah.
And Joe, what I do remember
is Joe was a regular
on that show.
He was on my round table all the time.
Cuz we had comedians
on and he was the best.
- There was no chemistry then?
- Well, he says I had a crush
on him during that time.
I also don't recall that.
- She doesn't recall anything.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Unless
it's a selective memory.
- We met through a mutual
friend, John Levitz.
- [Chelsea] Okay. Yeah.
- John Levitz was doing a
show at the laugh factory.
He was like, you have to meet Chelsea.
She's hysterical.
She's my only friend on MySpace.
- On MySpace?!
- MySpace.
So I went to his MySpace,
it was really Chelsea.
And then she started
coming on the shows and
and she told me about the show
that she was about to develop
and, and long story short,
she came up with an idea
that I was supposed to
be on the show and then
I turned it down and then
she just hated me forever.
- He says, I wanted, I
asked him to be my sidekick.
Remember Chewy?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He was my little nugget sidekick.
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
- Well apparently I went to
him first and Joe turned me
down and then I hired Chewy.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
You missed out.
- [Joe] Apparently she
doesn't remember any of that.
- No, not gonna had all
this love for that long.
Shame on you, Joe.
- Yeah.
- They're so awesome.
They're also totally honest,
which I love, especially
about their thoughts on each other.
Just look.
Do you like Valentine's
day do you celebrate?
- I love it.
- You do?
- Lopk who I got.
- [Kelly] Aw, you're romantic. I love you.
So you've never felt like pressure.
- No.
- [Kelly] Oh God. Okay.
Yeah. Me either.
Those are silly people.
- [Joe] But, but there's
pressure with this one though.
Cuz she doesn't want anything.
So it's like, don't take me to dinner.
Don't do anything.
- I don't want just yeah I don't.
I like, you know, do those
acts of kindness and love
on other days.
Surprise me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, cuz I also
think the anticipation
for so many women, we have
expectations and like that's also
unfair and ridiculous, you know?
And then you get disappointed so easily.
So it's better I think.
- [Kelly] Then each year you're
like, I did that last year.
- [Chelsea] Yeah, how
am I gonna one up that?
- Oh my God, it's stressful.
I'm so single and happy about it.
- Well enjoy your single time.
- I was like, it's like a lot of stress.
So wait, we saw a video
of your home life online.
So do you mind
if we show that you, already
showed everybody else?
Can we show?
- I don't see why not?
- [Kelly] Okay cuz we're
gonna do it anyway.
I have some questions.
So here we go.
Let's let's see this.
- Babe, it's all ice.
Oh it's ice in there.
Oh it's snow.
- [Chelsea] Honey, but
who told you do that?
- You told me!
Was there some kinda challenge?
- [Chelsea] No, I just
I told him his back hurt one
day after skiing and I said
why don't you go throw
yourself in that snow pile?
That's good for your circulation.
- Yeah.
- And he put some ice on it.
- [Joe] She goes ice your back.
And then she goes, out there.
- Oh my God.
I would've had to lost a bet.
Okay. So wait, be honest.
So what still annoys you about
the other person, you've got
like I've dated a musician,
that's hard like dating a comedian,
is that hard?
- He's pretty easy to get along with.
I mean the one problem
that we had the hurdle
in the beginning is he has sleep apnea.
So he has to wear a contraption
on his face in order for him to not die.
- Yeah 'cause you stop breathing.
- [Chelsea] Yes.
- Someone in my family has that.
Yeah.
- Yes. I, I like the fact that you said
that so he doesn't die and
your audience went hahaha.
- [Kelly] Why they're
laughing is that's so
not attractive, with
your sleep apnea machine.
- I'm right here, Kelly.
- I know, hey, I have a mouse
guard, retainer brother.
I'm not rocking it hot
when I go to bed either.
- Well take your mouth guard retainer,
multiply that time's a hundred
and that's what the sleep
apnea machine looks like.
- Oh, I've seen a sleep apnea machine.
My, my family has one.
- I look like Bane from Batman.
- And then so when he
goes to sleep, it's like
he's basically going into another,
like it's like going into a submarine.
Like he turns on this machine
and it makes this low rumble.
And then he takes a big gasp of air.
And then it's like,
he's gone for the night.
- [Kelly] Have you ever slept with him
when he's forgot to put it on
because what happens?
I have before with my mom and,
and all of a sudden she'll
like stop breathing.
And then all of a sudden it's like, yeah.
And like she like gasped
and I'm like, oh my God.
So don't not sleep with it.
- [Chelsea] Yeah, no,
I've warmed up to it now.
Now I understand that
it's keeping him alive.
You know?
So yeah.
- So I guess I'm willing to get on that.
- [Chelsea] Yeah, I mean
you said what's the most
annoying thing that wasn't
that was a big hurdle
for me cuz I was like
I could never be in a bed
with somebody that has to
put that on every night.
And now of course I can.
- She has to have something she does.
You don't have a retainer.
You don't have anything.
- I have. Yeah. I have like
a Invisalign, but again
it doesn't really compare
with what's going on with,
he looks like an octopus every
night when he goes to sleep.
So it's a different life.
- Well, that can be sexy.
- I love all these compliments.
- [Kelly] It's in the eye of the beholder.
- Happy Valentine's day.